[تصفيق
] فرصة
رفع الأعلام مرة أخرى في
ساحة الشهداء
في بيروت لإحياء الذكرى الثانية لانتفاضة جماهيرية
ضد النخبة
السياسية المحكومة يقول الكثيرون إنها أساءت حكم لبنان منذ
الحرب الأهلية
ولكن قبل عامين كان هناك
عشرات الآلاف من الناس
بضع مئات فقط
من المطالب لم تتغير ،
لكننا نريد حقوقنا التي نريد أن نعيشها مثل
أي شخص
آخر ويريدون المساءلة عن
الكوارث التي عانى منها هذا البلد
في السنوات الأخيرة ، فقد سهيل أسوس وظيفته
كمصمم داخلي الآن لديه
حان الوقت لبناء نموذج للمصير الذي
يأمله للسياسيين في لبنان ،
ما يهمه هو أن الناس بحاجة
إلى الاستيقاظ والنهوض واعتقال
جميع القتلة
والمحتالين لوضعهم في قفص حديدي وإحراقهم
عند الغسق الذي تجمعوه.  بالقرب من ميناء المدينة ،
رمز الإهمال القاتل
والفساد اللذين ابتلي بهما لبنان
لعقود
، وإفلات الطبقة الحاكمة من العقاب التي
لم تتم محاسبتها بعد.
منذ سنوات ، كان هناك شعور بأن
شيئًا ما كان يتغير ، لكن منذ ذلك
الحين انهار الاقتصاد اللبناني ،
وحدث
انفجار في ميناء بيروت في آب / أغسطس
عام 2020 ، أودى بحياة أكثر من 200 شخص
، وآخرها كان هناك حالة من الانهيار.  اشتباكات في
بيروت تذكر بالحرب الأهلية اللبنانية
مهما كان الأمل قبل عامين
، فقد تلاشى الكثير منه
بن ويتمان سي إن
بيروت.